So beginnt sie ihren Tag:
Sophie Chung könnte einen Zweimetermann
k. o. schlagen, aber darum geht es nicht.
Boxen ist eigentlich ’n sehr technischer
Sport, der ist eigentlich sehr komplex.
Das sieht auf den ersten Blick vielleicht
gar nicht so aus. Aber da gibt’s
unterschiedliche Schläge,
und man kann richtig oder falsch treffen.
Das merkt man auch sehr, sehr schnell.
Und für mich vereint Boxen auch sozusagen
die Kombination zwischen [von] Power
und Kraft und Ausdauer.
In Männerdomänen einzubrechen,
gehört zu ihrem Leben.
Ich persönlich, ich würd’ mir wünschen,
dass es … dass es mehr Frauen gibt,
die Kampfsport betreiben,
egal ob das jetzt Boxen ist oder Karate.
Die Welt braucht auf jeden Fall mehr
weibliche Klitschkos.
Und mehr weibliche Steve Jobs:
Start-up-Gründerinnen wie sie sind eher
die Ausnahme. Chung ist eigentlich Ärztin.
Seit 2015 betreibt sie eine Plattform
für Medizintourismus,
die weltweit Patienten an Kliniken
vermittelt.
40.000 waren es nach eigenen Angaben
bislang.
Im Gegensatz zu anderen Frauen traute
sie sich zu, eine Firma zu gründen.
Also, ich würde mir wünschen, dass Frauen
mutiger sind oft in vielen Situationen.
Vielleicht ’n bisschen weniger Selbstkritik
und Selbstzweifel an sich ausüben [üben]
und sich ab und zu auch einfach ’nen
stärkeren Ruck geben, sich zu trauen,
auch mal in die Welt rauszugehen und
etwas zu gründen.
Die größte Hürde beim Gründen:
Geld von Investoren eintreiben.
Chung wollte von ihnen 1,7 Millionen
Euro haben und schaffte es
– dank ihres selbstbewussten Auftretens,
aber vor allem dank ihrer Überzeugungskraft.
Man muss sein Team überzeugen
und motivieren.
Man muss mögliche zukünftige Geldgeber
überzeugen und motivieren,
eben diese Investition zu tätigen und
auch an dieses Unternehmen zu glauben.
Dass man eben überzeugen muss.
Und das muss man können,
und das ist ganz sicher eine der
Stärken von Sophie.
Gutes Alpha-Männchen trifft gutes
Alpha-Weibchen und
arbeitet als Team zusammen.
Chung hatte zuvor als
Unternehmensberaterin gearbeitet.
Wenn man gründet, da hat man mit sehr
viel Widerstand zu tun.
Man hat ’ne Riesenverantwortung,
die man tragen muss.
Man muss jeden Tag Entscheidungen fällen.
Und, ja, da braucht man dann schon
Eier aus Stahl.
Pause im Park mit den Angestellten:
Das gehört auch zum Firmenalltag
neben durchgearbeiteten Nächten
und ungewisser Perspektive.
Beides schreckt, so weiß Chung,
Frauen vom Gründen ab.
Weibliche Vorbilder, so meint sie,
könnten Ängste vertreiben.
Es mangelt definitiv an Vorbildern.
Das seh’ ich bei mir selbst.
Es gibt kaum eine erfolgreiche Gründerfrau,
zu der ich persönlich aufsehen kann
oder an der ich mir ein Beispiel
nehmen kann.
Und das ist ja mit vielen Sachen im
Leben so: Wenn es keine Vorbilder gibt,
wenn es weniger Menschen gibt, die
das vorleben, wie es funktioniert,
dann kann man sich das als junger
Mensch teilweise auch nicht gut vorstellen.
Und da verlässt einen ab und zu
auch der Mut.
Fast die Hälfte der Angestellten
sind Frauen.
Zufall, sagt die Chefin.
Frauen werden im Unternehmen
nicht bevorzugt.